the order of adjectives is one of those
wonderful linguistic things that no one
really notices until it's pointed out to
them in English you can have a big red
balloon but not a red big balloon you
can have a proper purple plastic panda
but not a plastic proper Purple Panda I
mean you can but it sounds off it sounds
wrong there is a rough rule in English
that says adjectives should be ordered
like this there are exceptions of course
particularly important adjectives should
be placed next to the noun but generally
this is how it works
general opinions are words like good or
important that could apply to anything
then you have specific opinions words
like delicious that can only apply to
certain categories of words then size
then shape it's never a round large
object it's a large round object then
the age then the color then the location
it came from then what it's made of you
can have a blue British wooden box but
not a wooden blue British box if it's a
that it implies that there's a thing
called a British box that's one of the
exceptions by the way if the noun is two
words like rocking-chair they always go
together at the end now this is more of
a guideline than a rule there are plenty
of ways to subvert it and the instinct
of many folks is to say well just means
you're putting the important bits near
the end except you aren't plus different
languages have different orders French
for example put some but not all after
the noun you'd have an grande Bala luge
now I would love to say that I could
explain adjectives ordering I wish I
could tell you why in English you can
have that big red balloon but not a red
big balloon but I have been searching
through the literature and while there
are plenty of descriptions of how it
works there is no consensus and frankly
very few theories about why but if you
wanna have a bit of fun with language
try playing about with the order when
you write sometimes it'll sound clunky
but who knows you may stumble on
something that will live on in and
here's something to confuse you even
further something that will live on in
time immemorial
you